what a story I have for you today Jared
Kushner Wonder Boy top Trump Advisor
son-in-law of the president previously
we knew that he didn't disclose a couple
of meetings with Russian officials but
now implosion blockbuster story from The
Wall Street Journal who by the way is
the child company of parent company News
Corporation which is also the parent
company of Fox News
we now have learned that Jared Kushner
didn't disclose his business ties with
Peter Thiel Goldman Sachs and I hope
you're sitting down for this George
Soros by being a part owner of cadre a
real estate startup that Jared Kushner
was involved in founding Jared Kushner
also did not disclose during his a sort
of disclosure process I mean that's what
it is that he owes a billion dollars in
loans to 20 different lenders and has
personally guaranteed 300 million
dollars of that billion dollars in debt
his lawyer is saying these revisions to
disclosures are totally normal nothing
to see here
ethics experts on the other hand say
that the loans and the personal
guarantees should have been disclosed
all along so that officials could decide
whether Kushner needs to recuse himself
from issues that involve of gore
organizations including the 20 lenders
that have loaned him money a source told
the Wall Street Journal that Jared
Kushner planned to repeat recuse himself
from anything that concerned Deutsche
Bank or RBS which are two of the 20
lenders that have given him money for
his properties or for companies which
he's provided personal guarantees on for
loans he still owes money to Bank of
America Blackstone Group Citigroup UBS
Deutsche Bank RBS as I mentioned all of
which were not disclosed now just
imagine for one second if this were
Barack Hussein Obama's son-in-law
what would Sean Hannity would would Rush
Limbaugh what would Bill O'Reilly well
actually Bill O'Reilly was fired so I
guess that's a bad example but definite
Sean Hannity and Rush Limbaugh what
would their entire shows look like right
now and perhaps the most fascinating
thing from this is that Jared Kushner
has ties to George Soros who's of course
the billionaire investor a lot of
Patriots actually point out that maybe
the David Pakman show is funded by
George Soros that's the furthest thing
from the truth but it turns out that
their own guy Trump's son-in-law and
senior advisor has direct connections to
Soros what does the committed trumpet
think of wonder boy being co investor of
a start-up with George Soros what if all
this was flipped ok I'll get to George
Soros more in a second what if this was
going on with a Democrat in the White
House it would be 24/7 demands for
impeachment for firings now let's take
the debt issue first and and then I do
want to get back to George Soros you
could say who cares about the debt Jared
Kushner will recuse himself if there's
anything at all involving any of these
20 lenders it's not just about recusing
himself when his creditors are involved
it's that when you have massive debt
that you personally guaranteed you are
exponentially more at risk to be bribed
and or to get involved in other types of
corruption and how ironic I mean really
to deal with the Soros thing how ironic
is it that right-wingers are constantly
trying to link anything on the left of
George Soros the women's March
protesters Planned Parenthood the David
Pakman show and it turns out that Jared
Kushner a top presidential advisor who's
involved in everything that's going on
in the White House right now is not only
linked to George Soros but is sharing
financial interests with him maybe with
all the responsibilities that Trump has
given to Jared Kushner he just entirely
forgot because owner is now in charge of
veteran reform criminal justice reform
reforming government ethics and even
solving peace in the Middle East
what will the dissonance be on the right
though because you're right this is a
guy who if you're concerned about George
Soros's involvement in things or as
Donald Trump likes to say very important
serious things then wouldn't you be
worried that George Soros has
shared interests with the guy that's at
the heart of all of the issues and more
that than the ones that Pat just
mentioned I believe the dissonance on
the right will be very strong Pat Obama
golf too much and he wore a tan suit
once when he was talking about serious
issues
forget about George Soros being tied to
Jared Kushner I don't think this is
going to really change the opinion of
that many committed trumpets I don't
know what you think about that either
they'll excuse it or they'll point out
that this Wall Street Journal article is
fake news oh yeah well that's a yes of
course which it's getting harder and
harder to argue that when you're talking
about traditionally conservative media
outlets and I know that some people will
hear me say that I'll say David the
editorial page of The Wall Street
Journal is not consistently right-wing
we're talking about a fiscally
conservative publication owned by News
Corporation to suggest that The Wall
Street Journal is some liberal rag out
to get Trump at this point seems hard to
believe so my son says Trumpets we'll
figure out a way out of this they'll say
oh no we I mean it's a concern when
Soros is involved with politics but this
is just real estate so therefore all of
a sudden George Soros is a completely
benign figure that we don't need to
worry about